good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday we are
so close to the end of the week give it
up for yourselves a big round of
applause for you
for making it good job everybody and
while we're giving big rounds of
applause
yes yes asha is a new york times
best-selling author number [ __ ] 12
[ __ ] number [ __ ] 12. oh my god and
you know what i just found out someone
dm
tom brady is number 12. i might have to
switch my super bowl bets because it's
it's kismet you know a hundred percent
so yes yesterday i got the call five
o'clock on the dot i literally knew i
had i knew i was finding out yesterday
and i knew it was a conference call at
five o'clock with like the publishers
and my agents and stuff
and i literally sat on my couch from one
o'clock to five o'clock just staring at
my computer i'm like what if it's time
for the conference call yet
and ben came home early and i recorded
my reaction because i'm like
honestly i didn't really expect to make
it because new york times bestsellers
list of course you have to sell
but it's not books it's about more
prestige and like
yeah they're curated yeah there are
other lists that are strictly based on
amount of books you sold like usa today
i was very very grateful to have made
the 22nd spot
in all books like it was a huge it was a
huge deal and that's like you know what
i feel really proud of that because like
that's people who picked up my book but
the new york times it's a weird they
don't tell you how to make it
it's a combination of people have to
have bought your book like a significant
amount a lot of people a lot of people
but also it's a prestige thing like it's
also
they chose you you know and so of course
because that reason alone i thought i
wasn't gonna get it because like you
know
i'm like a cancelled queen and nobody
wants to be associated with me
so i knew that like i had sold enough
books to make it but i didn't think that
they would have like hand selected me to
be a part of the list
me me and so that's why i didn't really
talk about it on the toast like i
i just i don't want to put it out there
because like i knew like it really
wasn't a possibility just given you know
my
my background and then
they called me and they were like
congratulations and i literally like
screamed from the top of my lungs i
couldn't believe it i literally cried
all night i had some drinks too that's
why but
i just like couldn't believe that like i
feel like my claim to fame is just like
being a disgraced queen yes
and this is extremely graceful it's it's
the new york times like it's
so [ __ ] graceful and i don't know i
just felt like this full circle moment
where like i just like have doubted
myself so much in the last year
and i always feel like i'm just like
being left behind because i'm like this
canceled disgraced queen
and to just and i don't even know if
they meant to but to be honored
by the new york times is so
not real like it's so crazy and i'm so
grateful of course to the new york times
thank you but to the toasters who like
showed up showed out like
my numbers were they refutable by the
totally they couldn't deny like i was
irrefutably a best-selling author
that is the power of the toast and so to
everyone who bought the book and
connected with the book or didn't even
read it and put it on their shelves like
that works for makes a sale is a sale
and thank you so much like we did it and
now like
to my grave now to the moon i'm
best-selling author
100 and there's a few people i would
love to thank honestly
of course the toasters first and
foremost for their unwavering support
and
support and second to my friends and
family you know
who were so supportive and they were
like you're gonna get it you're gonna
get it and i was like no i'm really not
but like you will have to pick me up
you know when i get the call that i
didn't get it also a very special thanks
to kelty knight who i really confided in
over the last few months over this
process because nobody has more
information on the new york times
bestsellers list than kelty knight she
knows who made it who didn't make it how
many books they sold so she was
constantly you know keeping me in the
loop
telling me you know what i needed to
hear and a great source of
support for me love to hear that and
then finally i would like to thank
myself
for doing it and writing a book and
you know what yeah yeah
yeah and never taking no for an answer
literally refusal of taking no for an
answer that's the moral of the story
the moral of the story here is that it's
never too late to like start over and
rebuild
and you know and i say this in the book
like a healthy
dose of delusion is so important when
curating your dreams
100 that's a beautiful claudia because
this is a delusional thing that happened
like it's not real but it wouldn't have
been possible without your
healthy dose of delusion that's what i'm
saying so we are so proud of you here at
the toast
we're so proud that we can say like one
of the hosts of morning toast is the new
york times best-selling author like that
just gives
the show a level of prestige that i
think we really needed and i think we're
kind of like
an award-winning show now i think you
could say that we're best-selling
show sure yeah okay
i mean we're already winning awards
right like peabody's nobel peace prizes
it's honestly exhausting having to fly
over the world to just like accept them
but we'll do it because we love it yeah
and i do like the nobel peace prize the
ones that we've gotten because they come
with a million dollar prize and
they do yeah the nobel peace prize you
get paid for
can you look that up i never get that
i'm pretty sure
it would make sense you get a million
dollars when you win a nobel peace prize
that would make sense but i've never
heard that yeah no i remember hearing it
and being like damn
i should have went to grad school you
know 100 percent
hundred percent however that i'm pretty
sure we're gonna double check
but i'm pretty sure that you win money
when you win a nobel peace prize i don't
know that's next i'll have to win one to
find out keep dreaming
keep dreaming you never know what can
happen you never know
million dollars and an 18 carat gold
medal
wow you learned something new every day
i had no idea i know i remember when i
found that
out i'm like that's so crazy like i
never thought i thought it was literally
just a plaque
yeah and the prestige and the honor of
course and like the press
yes of course which is worth its weight
you can't bypress that good
trust me i've tried well we're so proud
of you it's today's a great day
obviously you were so busy last night as
was i so we didn't watch real housewives
of salt lake city
yeah there will be no recap but i'm sure
everyone might understand
yeah no i was just like i was i knew
last night i was going to be drinking
very heavily
either as a celebration or a
commiseration
yes and i'm so glad it was the former
because i had such a great time i just
like was with three of my friends from
high school
and we played code names and we ate
burgers i had like a feasty vibes it was
so good like a kosher
feast wow yum speaking of feasty vibes
yesterday afternoon i cooked dinner at
i saw that you ate dinner at four
o'clock i ate dinner at 4 30 i started
cooking at three o'clock because i like
didn't really know what to do with
myself and we were
recording redheads later and like we
were recording redheads at dinner time
so i usually don't eat before and then
i'm so hungry and then i overeat after
so i was like i should just eat like a
whole meal before
i cook chicken parm from the half-baked
harvest cookbook and it was
so [ __ ] delicious the best thing i
ever cooked you would have loved real
chicken i used real chicken because i
had
like some meats in the freezer from when
i hosted shabbat i know how much you
love meats in your freezer
love no you claudia like you would have
loved it it was
delicious wow i mean i did see i did see
it and it looked good except i would
have used regular spaghetti instead of
zucchini noodles so it was half
spaghetti half zoodles oh and i've never
made doodles before but i got the
supervisor
and i made them myself and i i thought
it tasted so good and that way you're
eating like half healthy
but still tastes like spaghetti right no
that's interesting i would try that i
wouldn't have given it to you
still no you would have just given me
the rest of the plain pasta yes but it
was just
so good and i just felt like i really
treated myself are you pleased with the
half-baked harvest cookbook as
being the one of your choice and is it
better than aina's okay i think that my
palette
is closer to tegan's than it is to
aina's is what i've learned
and i do like the recipes that i've made
so far i just don't think there's that
many recipes i'm gonna be making from
the book because they're very involved
and like not and i think just above my
level pay grade and like when you are
kosher or like have us really specific
like dietary restriction list
there's only so many things you can make
it like you can't make anything with
shrimp
and i'm not gonna be cooking like steaks
in my house right so there's limited
options but you should get a kosher
cookbook too
yes i do have one but we were saying
like with a kosher cookbook then they
don't put meat and milk together and
then
oh wait we've literally had this
conversation so i'm just i feel really
pleased because i had some bad cooking
experiences but i'm feeling like really
good about it
the cast iron skillet is my new favorite
thing were you the one who called me
yesterday and said do you have a cast
iron skillet i did because i think that
you need one i think everybody loves one
yeah because it like cooks everything so
deliciously and unfortunately a cast
iron skillet now reminds me of emily in
paris
you know when he like gives her the
skillet yeah but it makes everything
like really delicious and it's like a
one pan dish which i realized i love
an opd an opd i feel that for sure less
dishes
also speaking of my night last night we
recorded the redheads and it was so
great and we had just gotten the news
about new york times bestseller so we're
all reacting and feeling really excited
honestly i had like fomo that you guys
would do an episode without me like
after we had like the best night ever
last month and then it's like you just
go back to like leaving me out you know
it wasn't the same i will say okay that
makes me feel good so if you want to
read
this book and then you can read the next
one too maybe i'll have you back on
you know what i think i might just have
trouble i've never been a part of a book
club before
but i'm just such an inconsistent reader
like
i read a whole book this like in in 12
hours yes like two days ago
and before that i hadn't read since
christmas break yeah so it's just like i
get an itch and i scratch
really [ __ ] hard and then i never
scratch again but that's what's so great
about being in a book club and i feel
this way about the redheads it's like
sometimes i go on hiatus from reading
but
doing the redheads always brings me back
at least once a month to reading one
book
and i'm always really grateful for it
like if i hadn't read the redheads book
this week i probably wouldn't have read
again for a while because i just like
wasn't really feeling it but now i'm
like ready to read again so it always
like resets you every month and i think
that's what's great about being in a
book club any book club
but the redheads is the best one is on
another level and also at the end of the
episode we made
such a exciting announcement about the
fact that we are dropping merch
oh yes in about two weeks stay tuned for
all of the details it's literally right
over there it's so sick
it's so sickening you guys i think even
non-redheads will have to purchase
that's me like hello also not only
dropping red heads merch but just look
out in the next couple months like tmt
merch is
being fired out of all cylinders the
most sickening designs you've ever
[ __ ] seen in your life no the ones
that are there's a
drop coming soon that the redheads is a
part of jackie can i
that no no because i because i said the
sweatshirt version like
the first thing that's seen but there's
a drop coming soon that the red house is
a part of that is sickening the merch
down
it's sickening the [ __ ] warehouse
down the warehouse is sick
yeah the warehouse has covered the
warehouse is infirm we have to get the
warehouse to the hospital
take its temperature rectally
we need help stay tuned for that i think
it's around like february 17th but
details coming soon um also a reminder
tomorrow is our last show of the week
and we're also going to be recapping our
toast movie of the week
so if you missed earlier in the week we
are bringing back toast movie of the
week for the month of february in honor
of black history month
highlighting black stories black
histories black history movies that
highlight the black community
this week's movie is the butler and
we're going to be recapping it tomorrow
so
don't forget to do that your homework
and
we're gonna be assigning another movie
on monday yes so excited yeah we've
gotten really good recommendations and
we've heard people
and i think a lot of people have raised
valid points like not every book or
movie or tv show um
that you watch like has to be about you
know the the hardest times in the black
history in black history
but also celebrate like the culture and
the community and i i felt that so
we're gonna diversify all the movies all
the choices i'm really excited but don't
forget to watch that it's streaming on
netflix so if you have netflix you can
watch it for free
can't wait okay i guess without further
ado
you know i mean i mean let me think like
as a new york times bestselling what do
you think you want to do
you know what time i feel like the
author and me sorry the new york times
bestselling author and me would just
want us to get to work like you know
because i'm obviously like a really hard
worker
right so i think we should do it you
think so i do okay without further ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and very appropriately today's episode
is brought to you by
bruce i wish we had bruce when we were
the morning breath like it just would
have been
a hundred percent also sorry i'm pausing
the ad
the fact that i made the new york times
bestsellers list is a miracle but the
fact that i
was on top of a book called breathe or
breath breath
breath is just poetic justice and you
know hashem he works in mysterious ways
but i saw that hashem thank you very
much god is a literal comedian
call me comedy queen queen
okay today's episode is brought to you
by bruce the best electric toothbrush on
the market you guys need it in your life
jackie and i talk about it almost every
day even when it's not sponsored
it it works super super well like i went
to the dentist and you went to the
netherlands and someone else told me
that she went to the dentist after
getting a brush and the dentist was like
wow your brushing has gotten so much
better
and they were like what kind of brush is
it and she's like doc it's a brooch
it's works really really well and it's
so reasonably priced because so many of
these
um electric toothbrushes that are on the
market or it costs over 200
which is crazy like crazy but bruce is
very reasonably priced and you save
money because it's a sustainable
uh option you don't have to buy a new
one every six months and they have a
subscription service now that can save
you money on refilling
your replaceable heads so it's just
really fabulous it's everything of the
sort claudia and i both have the pink
brush but i was actually just on the
brush website like looking at the other
colors do they have new seasonal colors
the colors are so sickening and it's
like i already have my brush and i love
it
but i just i'm like really tingling for
that blue bruce i think we gotta get a
new one maybe get it for zach
yeah that's true so the brush it's bruce
excuse me itself
has six unique modes to customize your
brushing experience and the battery life
lasts four weeks
the magnetic charging stand um comes in
a compact travel case
so if you're traveling you actually
don't need to bring your charger unless
you're charging for
traveling for more than four weeks in
which case jealous the subscription
program helps you never forget your
brush head again
because bruce will ship you new
replacement heads every six months so
you're never stuck using a worn down
brush head
their sleek design has a modern
aesthetically pleasing design and comes
in trend driven seasonal colors
and looks great on your bathroom counter
very true it's not bulky it's elegant it
literally looks like it was designed
at spacex with elon musk 100 elon
definitely
he's an investor for sure i don't know
that for a fact but i just have a
feeling
yeah get 15 off your bruce toothbrush
kit and refill plan when you use promo
code toast at bruce.com
that's 15 off using promo code toast at
bruush.com
love it okay first story an update to
last week's
news madison lacroix says she has quote
never been physical
unquote with alex rodriguez okay so in
the last 24 hours
danny baird like went on a podcast and
spilled it all
spilled the beans saying that the ex-mlb
player
is a-rod and now madison has broken her
silence on the alleged relationship
exclusively telling page six
that she and the ex-mlb star have never
met in person and only spoke on the
phone
so she clarified that they've quote
spoken on the phone that's the truth she
said adding that they've never been
physical
never had any kind of anything just an
acquaintance
which is what we got from the reunion
and then so a rep for a-rod was like
these rumors are bogus he's never met
her
and it's like you know she's never true
that is true they're both telling the
truth but he was
definitely reaching out they've never
met and even if all you know they were
never physical like an engaged man
having a phone relationship even if it
was like platonic business whatever
a phone relationship with like a like a
reality star who's 20 years younger than
your fiance like it's so inappropriate
on so many
relationship with anyone like and it's
clear that it's not like he just watched
southern charm and was taking
madison he's not a big fan of the show
like this is
apparently as we found out in last week
like this is what a-rod does
yeah and you know like i am always the
first person to like come down on danny
baird but like honestly
everyone knew it already so it's like
not that big of a deal that she spilled
the beans
yeah and she's obviously like so clearly
still mad at madison for the whole
gonorrhea thing
so i think in a lot of ways this was
like her final act of revenge
yeah also i i think everybody sort of
knew it was a right but no one wanted to
say it because that could be
libelous and everyone's like allegedly
they said and i mean all these instagram
accounts are just saying because
apparently can you just do that on
instagram
yeah you can just share anonymous rumors
yeah
so i am glad that danny just like put it
yeah but also um oh [ __ ] what i was
gonna say
i was gonna say danny madison
yeah defamatory uh-huh
yeah yeah yeah i'm clear i it wasn't
that interesting because this story is
like kind of getting boring
it is but it's always good to have
clarification it's also the craziest
thing that like this little
reality show is like so making the
sports world no
it's like fiance jayla's fiance what i
was going to say was that
they did call him multiple times on the
reunion and married ex-mlb player
which is not entirely true so that's why
a lot of people were like it
it's probably a-rod but they said
married yeah that was confusing but
he's engaged like it's i think at this
point it's just semantics yeah
to me like they're married yeah but then
they're actually now acts like this like
what is jayla gonna do about this
you know this is what we we say time and
time again it's like when women like j
lo
and beyonce like even they their men are
like [ __ ] around on them like
how are we expecting is there any hope
for the rest of us it's just it's so
disappointing
it's so disappointing i just how can she
stand
by him now like i clearly it's so
embarrassing it's so embarrassing like
this is what he does there are now all
these other things and it's like what's
the
i don't get it like why yeah and like
for so long i shipped these two so hard
like i built the biggest mega yacht in
the caribbean for these two like
i thought they were the perfect couple
in so many ways like
we literally couldn't decide who's more
rich they're on the same level fame-wise
money-wise
they both are like so proud of their
their cultures like
i just thought this was the best couple
maybe in the history of hollywood like i
really felt that way
but he has really sullied sully than
the lopez chesley sullied sullenberger
it's disgusting
this relationship i do find it so
interesting that madison lacroix like
even though she's on like a small bravo
reality show like
keeps finding her way into the phones of
like
major celebrities and athletes and i
would just love to know like her secrets
and like
if if these two like these are two now
like really messy public like
things going on will this hinder her
future possible relationships with other
athletes i don't know and i also have to
wonder i do think like
it's just kind of coincidental that
she's like was talking to the two
most famous athletes because the jay
cutler thing was like a spite thing like
if it wasn't for austin and craig
talking to kristen like she never would
have gotten communication with jay
and it's clear that i don't know and she
was never really speaking like annoying
like she was never bragging about it
like andy asked her about her on watch
robin's live and she's like that's
private
yeah but with a rod it's like does he
watch the show and sought her out
or did he just see her instagram it's so
weird i literally don't know
i would just love to know like the
origins of their story like how they
came to come in contact with one another
yeah yeah i agree i swear you guys i'm
not picking my nose on the youtube today
my nostrils are so
itchy interesting that means i mean you
know when like when your armpits are
itchy like someone's talking [ __ ] about
it
your palms are itchy like you're coming
into money oh [ __ ] i wish my palms were
already changed it's like your nostrils
are itchy
what is that new york times bestseller i
think oh too bad i guess i'll have to
scratch scratch
okay next story look at little dude why
is he so
dirty have you seen outside jackie
that's true that's true
did i have i ever mentioned on the show
what new york looks like after it snows
no you haven't and also what happened at
dennis's funeral
stop that's so mean you guys like are
always being mean to me even theo
always getting up on me
he was actually a torture fest in the
bed last night after we did that dear
toasters yesterday i think i jinxed
myself because i'm like
we have a perfect situation i sleep on
one side
theo's in the middle and we all fit
perfectly
oh my god like hashem laughing in my
face
he was torture fest i literally was
lying on my stomach he
stepped on my back circled and laid
directly on my back in like a little
swirly ball bruno has done that to me
roberto is so light he always almost 20
pounds yeah he weighs
more than that yeah no um shut the [ __ ]
up
okay just shut the [ __ ] up okay are you
ready for our next story
he was almost 30 pounds no he was 20
like 21.
i mean honestly like we've all gained a
little in the queue
listen shut the [ __ ] up like theo's in
such perfect health
no i'm not on wood i didn't say anything
negative about him i think he's a
beautiful boy
theo are you hearing this yeah he's like
thank you auntie
i don't think that's what he's saying
are you ready for our next story i guess
because morgan wallin's label
suspends him and definitely as country
radio drops
his songs after he used a racial slur
morgan wallin is being suspended from
his label and his songs are being pulled
from hundreds of radio stations and cmt
nationwide as i heart media and cumulus
media the two biggest radio station
groups in the us
along with cmt pulled his music from
their airwaves after wallin was captured
using the n-word in a video obtained by
tmz on tuesday
his record label is quote indefinitely
suspending him his record label big loud
put out a statement saying in the wake
of recent events big loud records has
made the decision to suspend morgan
wallen's recording contract indefinitely
republic records fully supports big
loud's decision and agreed such behavior
will not be tolerated
i mean it's it's definitely i think the
right move
and and honestly like i think that i saw
first because i was thinking i'm like i
wonder if there's going to be any like
career repercussions for him like
obviously like
the public is very mad at him but will
there be like actual business
repercussions and the first and i have
to commend cmt they were the first i saw
and then once they said that they were
going to pull all of his performances
other people then followed suit and like
nobody wants to be the first one you
know
oh i didn't see that cmt had been the
first i think the first thing that i saw
was his record label right because that
was the biggest news but it happened
after like a few other
like smaller organizations did it um and
the thing is is like i was thinking
about this morning it's so disappointing
on so many levels but mostly because
that fake ass apology like written to
like tmz from a publicist yeah like it
was just so insincere when like
something like this requires like a
really
genuine apology to the black community
like it's
and it's not even my apology to accept
or not accept but i i know a shitty
apology when i see it
that's what makes the whole situation
even more disappointing like there
appears to be no effort from him to like
give a [ __ ]
yeah at least not yet and the video came
out and then he had like this
statement written there was no like time
of reflection or anything
which it was a strange way to go about
it i'm sure we'll be hearing from him
again at some
point i mean it even just like not even
for career-wise like for his own soul
like you just owe people an apology and
like a camp it doesn't feel good to like
have all that like
pent up like 100 it's this whole story
is so
disappointing and yesterday like i was
really down about it um but then i
decided to read the
time magazine tj osborne article where
he comes out and his him and his brother
are both interviewed and i literally
like got choked
the [ __ ] up reading this article it was
so beautiful of course like because his
story is incredible
but also because the support from his
brother and he was like you know
and they're like they're country but
they're not mainstream country they're
actually like
more country than like cma awards like
they're more redneck
and like that just makes it like so much
bigger of a deal and he was like
you know when we're playing shows in
chicago i don't think anyone's gonna
like you know chant me off the stage but
like if we're doing county fairs like in
the middle of nowhere like you
really never know and like that's what
remains to be seen for them
and the brother was like no like when he
told me i was so happy and when he told
me he wanted to come out
publicly i didn't doubt it for a second
and i was so supportive of him and like
if
all of this went away but he got to live
his best life like i would be so happy
and it was literally like i was
crying listen reading this article it
was so sweet
and i stand tj osborne and i have um the
perfect man for him so if someone from
his camp
could get in contact with me do you yeah
oh that's so exciting
well because i immediately thought i'm
like this guy's tall and handsome and
successful like
gotta set him up with tpg and then
literally late last night tbg dm'd me
his instagram story and was like who is
this like
got it and i'm like brian get with him
yeah i think there's such a cute little
piece everyone so i don't know if he's
dating anyone because he's been keeping
his you know love life very private but
if he
wants a [ __ ] up tj come to aunt claudia
i've got you
j x tpg sickening reigns so sickening
i've got my ship building materials i'm
ready to set sail i know that's so
stunning i know
okay well our next story is related
because jojo siwa says her super
encouraging girlfriend inspired her to
come out she's a girlfriend
yes on wednesday night the youtuber
chatted with jimmy fallon on the tonight
show starring jimmy fallon where she
gushed about her super encouraging
sweetheart
who prompted her to share her truth with
her followers can i say one thing really
quickly like not about the story just
about jimmy fallon
so jimmy fallon obviously had jojo siwa
on and olivia rodrigo
i think tonight or last night is going
on fallon which is like such a big deal
and it does feel very weird to have this
like 40 year old man like be involved in
like the sabrina carpenter of it all
and i just feel like so many young
people are like making so much news
recently like there needs to be a show
on television for young people that's
all i was gonna do that's a really good
point
like jimmy fallon talking to jojo like
what's going on
just one at least just what literally
one kid's like
like evening show yeah or one late night
show
hosted by someone like under 30. but
like the kids go to sleep early that's
what's tough
no i'm not talking about 11 year olds
like no no but like if it's geared for
like jojo siwa fans like her fans are
asleep
okay i'm just saying like there needs to
be something maybe not late night but i
agree where it's like
it's not really weird that like jimmy
fallon is talking to olivia rodriguez
right like a 17 year old talking to like
an over 40 man
i want to say almost 50. like yeah i
feel you
okay jojo told jimmy fallon that she
felt emboldened to share the image while
filming with a group of lgbtq plus tick
talkers called pride house assuming the
crap
the collaboration would quote out her
anyway she said i don't really mind
because it is true i do have the most
amazing wonderful
perfect most beautiful girlfriend in the
whole world
one day i was on facetime with my
girlfriend and i was like i kind of just
want to post this picture on my
instagram story she explained
she said she was super encouraging she
was like do it and i was like all right
and i did it and then i went back to
facetiming with her
thankfully fans have been overwhelmingly
supportive but siwa admitted it was a
really big wrist
this is really sweet what she said and
it reminds me of the tj article she said
quote
if i lost everything that i've created
because of being myself and because of
loving who i want to love
i don't want it if i can't love who i
want to love it's one of the
most important things to me that's so
sweet i'm literally going to cry
oh my god she's such a role model like
honestly
we make fun of jojo but i'm done we
don't no no because she's a little magic
cigarette
joe joined her magic cigarettes but jojo
and magic cigarettes but like honestly
in this house we [ __ ] stand jojo siwa
oh that was so sweet so she's such a
role model like
kids these days are so lucky to have her
and what a good head she has on her
shoulders to be able to like
see that it's like all of this i'm sure
she has so much
wealth and opportunities and excitement
and these things that going on in her
career and it's like if she can't be who
she wants to be in love who she wants to
love she then what's the point
send it back oh oh my god i love her so
much like
she's a queen oh my god yeah like you
know what if you had told me like this
year josie was gonna become an lgbtq
plus icon i like never would have
believed you but like here we are like
she's literally changing the world
her impact huge huge okay next story
is it the next story brought to you by
imperfect foods
it is exciting
well imperfect foods is on a mission to
reimagine grocery delivery for a kinder
less wasteful world they deliver
sustainable affordable groceries
including produce quality protein
eggs and dairy and pantry staples
straight to your door
plus they are always adding fun and
tasting new discoveries for you to try
each week all you have to do is sign up
and create your flexible personalized
grocery plan
and then shop online each week and get
affordable and sustainable groceries
delivered directly to your door
with imperfect foods grocery shopping
fits seamlessly into your life and every
week is a tasty adventure
sign up within perfect foods today to
save time money and food from going to
waste
and right now in perfect foods is
offering our listeners 20 off
plus free shipping on your first order
when you go to imperfectfoods.com and
make sure to use promo code
toast try imperfect foods now for a
limited time to get 20
off plus free shipping on your first
order go to imperfectfoods.com and use
code toast to sign up
so that offer again is 20 off plus free
shipping
at imperfectfoods.com promo code
toast so i'm always looking for new ways
to get food to my house like without
having to leave the house and imperfect
foods has
great selection of food probably my
favorite that i've seen so
check it out imperfect foods check it
out lamar odom and aaron
carter will be fighting in a celebrity
boxing match this summer
retired nba star lamar odom and former
pop star aaron carter are set to face
off in a celebrity boxing match this
summer according to a report
celebrity boxing ceo damon feldman told
tmz sports that the three-round
exhibition will take place at the
showboat casino in atlantic city new
jersey on june 12. now the story just
gets sadder and sadder
atlantic city they can't even get vegas
like
odom and carter have already started
training in the gym for the big event
according to the outlet odom who played
14 seasons with the nba stands tall at 6
10 while aaron carter is 6-1
this is not even like this isn't even a
like a competition yeah no laura odom is
obviously going to win
despite the height difference carter
says he is excited to face odom in the
ring
carter's told tmz this is a crazy
match-up it's like david and goliath i'm
really looking forward to this fight
i mean this is some loser on loser
fighting like it's so
weird and so lame and honestly i feel
sad for lamar odom that he's like gotten
to this place in his career where this
is something he's actually considering
doing like no he didn't consider it
like he signed up yeah he signed the
contract whereas like aaron carter just
like has
like spiraled to this place and it like
makes sense but like lamar odom was like
sixth man of the year he was with the
kardashians like and and
so much happened in his life that like
you know got him to a bad place and i'm
really happy that he's like back in
fighting shape and healthy but like
literally
i'm just sad that he's not like living
in calabasas and like
that he's not too good for this because
in my mind he is yeah i agree
also like the fact that this fight seems
very unfair but you never know
right like maybe we'll be watching also
it's in june which seems really far away
yeah maybe aaron carter can grow a
little bit
he's tilted oh like
crazy you know i'm sure that's what
they're both doing right now i cannot
wait for floyd mayweather and logan paul
like that's gonna be the best night of
my life i think i'm gonna have like
a fight gathering at night when is it i
don't know speaking of big sporting
events the super bowl is very soon so
get your bets in
yeah get your picks in i'm still not
sure you're still
sure i know you're drawn to number 12.
yeah i don't know
maybe that was the sign that you needed
maybe i just like
i really do love rooting for an underdog
and like i think the obvious choice is
the bradys
so i'm going to stick with my choice and
i really i i feel very supportive about
the obvious choice oh it's the birdies
yeah and i feel very um supported by the
people of kansas city like you know they
sold out my show
yeah the people in tampa did too but it
was a much smaller venue so
i don't know judging by that alone yeah
yeah and i just like i
i really respect how much people from
kansas city like respect their hometown
do you know what i mean yeah
like they have so much hometown pride
it's so admirable i
[ __ ] hate this place no i agree i
think it's gonna be a great game yeah
can't wait to find out what happens on
monday morning still have no plans ben
is going to a party and he's like
it's all guys like i can ask if i can
bring you i'm like ugh that is so
insulting like can i bring my wife like
what like it's
so embarrassing hundred percent maybe i
should have the girls over make chicken
parm
yeah no like maybe we could do something
like more fun to make ben jealous
but yeah for sure how cool is that i
want to use my cast iron skillet to make
spinach artichoke
oh that's a great idea and then will you
come over ben will be jealous of
that and then also we'll have all the
pups over he'll be jealous of that
that for sure okay fifth and final story
hurts it really hurts but i'm still
holding out hope kim kardashian has
little contact with kanye west
a source says that she quote has a
divorce plan in place there have been
like
and he moved over 500 pairs of shoes out
of the closet he moved over 500 pairs of
shoes out of the closet and she showed
off her new skin showroom in her house
which looks a lot like the closet that
kanye used when david ladderman was at
their house but the argument could also
be made that they have his in her closet
they literally mirrored and that they
look exactly the same yeah that didn't
convince me of anything but
i do think like it's like people like
move closets all the time like things
happen yeah the
rich people are like constantly shifting
their clothing yeah like maybe like she
took over his and then he got a
different way like that's just
no i think i can explain my way out of
it but i just feel like right news isn't
slowing down about this
right you could talk your way out of it
but i don't know if it's necessarily
like the truth i think that
we might you know have to
reconcile what the truth is yeah and i'm
if that is what comes to be i will be
able to reconcile
it but until then i'm allowed to have
hope i know you're allowed to have
doubts like of the story
yeah and like until kim tells me like i
just
i don't i don't need to act i don't need
to feel anything that's completely fine
thank you thank you for respecting my
boundaries so what was the story
that he's like moved out in there really
but we also know that he's been living
in cody for over a year
so like but that she has a divorce plan
in place and that they're no longer
doing marriage counseling they're living
separate lives
who wrote this they have no contact
people magazine
it's not it's not that unreliable you
know mm-hmm
that's upsetting yeah
so so some of us came here stands maybe
have to start
swallowing the shirts maybe have to
start repurposing our ship
material for a new boat that's okay
it hurts hurts well i can't even think
about it that's gonna just be the
craziest thing but also
i just feel like the way that this news
is coming out it's like so delayed and
staggered
it's by the time it finally like drops
everyone will be kind of like immune to
it i think maybe that was like the point
yeah i think that's called strategy like
in the pr world oh interesting it's a
good strategy
um those are the stories and i
definitely i feel so you needed to know
them i feel as though you definitely
needed to know them
it's been a big busy week and also you
must know that claudia is a new york
times best-selling author
um we also have uh okay so tomorrow is
our final show of the week we're gonna
be recapping
uh lee daniels the butler you know i
don't know why i literally
thought the name of that movie was lee
daniels the butler i know but it's lee
daniels is
the butler but like lee daniels presents
but the way that it is
and the way that people spoke about it
when it was like coming out they were
like lee daniel's butler
yes i agree but i know like lee daniels
is a filmmaker so i'm like it's lee
daniels this is the butler yes but now
it's like i keep every time i search and
i'm like lee daniel's the butler
and it's just it's just called the
butler like
no it's it's really interesting how that
happened so i'm gonna watch that today
because i haven't watched yet because
you know i'll forget if i watch it
anything farther than one day before um
so make sure to watch it if you haven't
watched it yet
and we'll be recapping it tomorrow and
we also have a fabulous interview on
tomorrow's episode
so stay tuned for that stay tuned
tomorrow's gonna be a big day and
hopefully we'll be recapping real
housewives of salt lake city tomorrow
and southern charm and southern charm i
um i am celebrating my new york times
bestseller authorship again tonight
oh you are anything exciting where's my
invite um
it's like in the mail okay well you know
what i have a really busy day planned so
i'm just saying like if i get to
southern charm like i'll get to it but
i'm just like
i'm celebrating me and and i can't you
know be sorry for that no i agree
and usually i would take you celebrating
you to mean that like i don't have to
watch either but i'm
actually like excited to watch it's not
just a chore so
hopefully i will be watching okay well
that's why i wouldn't
have an amazing day but you never know
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast
the millennium morning show where we
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube
so if you're watching us on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found
really anywhere spotify itunes stitcher
public radio iheartradio cast box
all the places so wherever you listen to
podcasts find us the morning toast and
leave a 5 star review about how
beautiful
stunning and smart we are hope you guys
have an amazing thursday and we'll see
you back here tomorrow
for friday friday
gotta get down on friday